hey guys my name is Ben I work at
Virginia Tech Applied Research
Corporation as a data visualization
engineer and I'm here to talk to you
about graphs but just so you know I mean
you might not want to follow along you
might want to follow along but all the
information that we're gonna go over
today the code the slides can be found
on my repository Benjamin Ortiz who you
ah back /dc PI data 2018 so if you want
to play around with a code if you want
to explore there's a there's an AI or
there's a Jupiter notebook there to play
around with just have fun okay so let's
start out so the formula this log is
going to be I'm going to go over the
following things basically I'm just
gonna go into introduction what is a
graph then I would go into practical
applications like what how to make a
recommendation system with a graph
wouldn't follow up with like an
understanding of like the measurement
and impacts the measurements of impact
and importance of a graph or let the
nodes of the graph follow that up with
an understanding of how to use these
metrics actually like extract key
phrases from a corpus of documents and
then I'm gonna briefly explain what a
agent-based model or a network model is
and then we're gonna go over some code
and I'm just going to close off with a
few announcements okay so what is a
graph so a graph is made up of things
and things are also known as nodes and
edges nodes and edges are essentially
this different words for the same thing
and these things are connected to each
other with relationships also known as
links and edges these relationships can
have directions so if you think about
Twitter I can follow somebody they don't
necessarily follow me back
that's a directed relationship and there
can be multiple relationships which came
to two things so I can follow somebody
they can follow me back or they don't
that's the direction that's the multiple
connection between two people so a cool
thing about graphs is that each of these
things whether it's an edge or a note
they can all store and even the graph
itself can store data so like people if
you actually have people as nodes they
have hair colors that can be stored in
the node they have jobs they could that
could be stored in the node they have
just I any kind of history anything that
could be like saved on an entity or
relationship can be stored in a note or
an edge and the cool thing about these
attributes that can actually be
visualized into a graph so why do we
care about the relationships in a graph
well it's basically because they provide
context so you have like two people that
are friends or they like each other but
what does that mean in the greater scope
of the the the network or the graph so
like two people who like each other I
could like each other because they have
the same friend group or they hate the
same person right that's a way that
people can actually bond and that's
actually pretty well-known in like
social networks so let's think about
this like things networks are dynamic
I'm not always the same friend with the
same people sometimes I just we fall
apart or some I get really mad at
somebody and I really don't wanna be
friends with them so what happens when
that happens what happen if I stop
liking somebody what if I get mad at
somebody what does that happen what
happens to my friend group what happens
to the actual graph well in this in this
example you don't really know because
it's a really small graph we have more
context however if we actually get we
actually see the full network we can
kind of like infer what's going to
happen if if my friend group is not
contingent on the person I dislike then
I'm gonna go to place like I'm probably
gonna still have my same friends however
the other person who I started dislike
was not as embedded in that friendship
group that person is probably going to
get ostracized from the group and that's
a one way to actually analyze a social
network or any kind of network in
general so another cool thing about
nodes and edges a node attributes is I
know to attribute could actually be
stored as its own node and this is a
like another way of actually calling
this as a bipartite graph so if I have
an attribute like a hair color that hair
color could actually be its own node
that actually could be its own node and
we could actually use that to form like
get infer similarities or some kind of
indirect connections between two
entities so here like we have certain
nodes that are circle certain nodes that
are a color blue and certain large notes
and we actually use that to actually
make an indirect connection and then we
can project that into the actual just
its own little graph it's a little sub
graph made from these indirect or
correct connections so
we just talked about like a structure of
a graph and actually just kind of like
the the architecture of a graph that in
its own right is enough to create a
recommendation system and like the
reason why recommendation systems are
important is because well like a little
study came out a little while ago saying
thirty five percent of all consumers buy
on Amazon it's ninety five percent of
what users watch on Netflix come from
product recommendations so that's a
these are product oriented companies so
that's a big impact on their business so
recommendations are important especially
if you if you care about selling things
if you care about like people continuing
their subscription to your service you
want to do whatever you can to actually
keep them going and a recommendation
system is the way to do that and so the
cool thing is this just just analyzing
the structure just following nodes and
edges in the graph is enough to actually
do this I don't want to explain how so a
way to do this with content-based
recommendation systems is let's say I
bought a I phone or an iPod what is an
iPod well an iPod is an Apple product
and it's a musical product so let's say
am I in my inventory I have other
products that are both Apple products
and musical products so there's the the
Mac computer there's the earbuds there
Mac earbuds and then there's just the
Bose earbuds
what should I recommend what should be
recommended to the person who bought the
I the iPod well the the only there's
only one thing that actually has to just
kind of truly it has the most attributes
in a relationship with the iPod and
that's the Apple earbuds and so we're
gonna recommend that because they're
simply just the amount of connections it
shares with the product that I've
already bought and there's another way
of doing this called collaborative
filtering so I bought both a Mac
computer and an iPod who are other
people that bought these things so
there's one person who bought just the
Mac computer there's one person who
bought both products is the same thing
and so we could use that as a proxy to
understand that I am similar to the
person in the bottom right and because
of that I'm going to suggest the other
thing that that person the bottom right
has bought that I have not bought so
that's another way to actually format a
recommendation system simply unlike what
people bought and that's again this is
just the structure of the graph and
we're following in the graph and we can
already like get a lot of insights
simply by following the connections
so graphs have like graphs can get
really large and it becomes difficult to
actually realize what's important know
what's an important agent within that
graph and the way we do with the way we
can actually identify the important
notes in the graph is through these
these these measurements so before you
actually go into some of the measurement
a lot of these measurements are
dependent on a thing called like are
dependent on shortest paths and
diameters so I sorta Spath between two
notes is the traversal of like a an edge
and a node from one to the other that is
actually the takes the least amount of
hops so you'll see here this is the
largest shortest path so that these are
the paths these are the nodes that are
like the farthest from each other and so
if we follow it this will be able to
show us like how how wide the graph is
and that's also called the diameter so
if we analyze all the shortest paths
between all vertices like like every
single vertice and their path to and
every other privacy you'll start seeing
similar you'll start seeing a lot of
vertices popping up showing up a lot and
those are those would be called like
those will have the higher betweenness
centrality measurement the betweenness
centrality measurements simply says if
you if you're in all the most shortest
paths you are more important and again
like because graphs can be directed if
it's a if it's a if it's a directed
graph simply like the shortest
connections is a necessarily point you
have to follow the actual arrow so it's
a short connection between arrows
they'll show you that heights between us
there's also the degree which is simply
the the number of nodes a single node
like is connected to so like at with
like if I step out once if I step out
from one node to another node how many
nodes can i how many nodes am I gonna
like potentially jump into and that's
and that depends that again depends on
like the direction you care about not
like I could have I could be on Twitter
I can follow a lot of people not a lot
of people are following me so that means
I have a very high out degree because
I'm like if the direction of my
following is going outwards I've a laugh
you job degree not so big of a in degree
because not so many people are following
me back and these are these can actually
be like shown
in the graph itself and you can just
find like general degrees as well if you
don't care about direction they can just
find out all the connections you have
and another thing is closeness closeness
is how close you are to every other edge
like like the he has the minimal
shortest pass to every single other node
in the graph and again Direction matters
and then there's hub scores which if in
the days of like the early days are like
search and like in the internet a hub a
hub was considered a website that
actually pointed to other web sites a
lot so if you think about Wikipedia we
could be that does have its own content
but a lot of it times a lot of the value
in Wikipedia is that it points you to
other things it references other web
sites and it references other things and
those things that it references are
called authorities so if you have a lot
of web sites point to you if you have a
lot of important web sites like
Wikipedia pointing to you or like if you
are considered an authority and an
authority would be actually like the
main like a main web site so the
authority on Ford cars would be the Ford
website that would be an example of that
you don't necessarily for doesn't
necessarily point to other other
websites but a lot of websites will
short like what point was forward if
they came out with like a giant press
release and a combination of these
things so like hub the hub score and the
authorities score are very much
connected a combination of that and this
is what made Google pretty famous is
something called a PageRank so hub
scores and authority scores are their
own separate metric a PageRank kind of
combines those two into a single metric
basically saying like it's both and port
it's important because it got pointed to
and it's important because it's pointing
to a lot of other important things and
so these metrics have can actually be
used because these metrics are important
in like whether it's like traversing the
websites or whether it's traversing
social networks but it can also be used
on other things like texts so we're
gonna actually analyze the PI data about
me page
this is the the information on PI data
PI data well PI data conferences bring
together users and development areas of
data analysis tools text there's text
here and there's the cool thing about
text is that it actually has a natural
flow of things so if you actually follow
a text from the first letter to the
second letter to the third letter if you
just actually create an arrow between
words that's going to create the graph
for you and we're gonna actually create
that as a text graph and then we're
gonna iterate over it we're gonna only
keep the words that are both nouns and
adjectives we're gonna run a PageRank or
algorithm on that text graph and then
we're gonna keep a guy at the top third
page ranked vertices and that's gonna
provide us with like if if two words are
still connected after this that's when
we consider a key phrase and we're just
gonna pull that out this is the text
ranking algorithm so this is an example
of a techni so the first sentence in the
pie data page this is an example of like
what a this is how you would actually
form the graph now let's actually look
at what it looks like when you have to
all the text from this pie data page and
this is the this is the actual this
would be the equivalent of the full text
graph for pie data if we run that on the
PI data page we get these two key
phrases we get community or community
gathers which might not necessarily be a
good phrase but we also have analysis
tools which is absolutely a big point of
Pi data so that's like a that's really
cool and this is like a directed version
of it so like again text rank could be
either directed or undirected depending
on the algorithm you use if we actually
pull the undirected
however when we get these key phrases
from the PI data side we get the topical
workshops we get package developers we
get evolving challenges PI data
community and community driven
conference these are absolutely key
phrases that can be that should and can
be pulled out from the PI data website
simply by traversing a graph simply by
doing a graph metric or a graph a simple
graph algorithm on text on a single web
page and the same thing can be done with
the code of conduct
the only word that got pulled out of the
PI Denis code of conduct is different
backgrounds that's the only Kieffer's
that got out from the director text rank
and the undirected text frame has other
stuff like exclusionary jokes there's a
concept
a friendly event professional audience
body size gender identity those are all
the concepts just got pulled simply by
traversing the graph and so the next
thing I want to talk about is like graph
models so this is a lot of fun and this
is stuff I'm like just exploring right
now so there's an idea that like because
you can store attributes into a node and
you can actually change those attributes
with time you can actually follow the
changes of these nodes and actually see
how they're they affect each other so in
epidemiology there's this concept of
contagion models and there's and it
starts off with a simple thing like
certain nodes are infected certain nodes
are susceptible if I'm connect if a
susceptible node is connected with an
infected node the next T the next time
period that you're actually iterating
over those susceptible nodes will become
infected that's considered that's a
simple SI model where it's called
susceptible and infected so if you're
connected by susceptible note if it
wasn't a susceptible node become
infected then it infects it's in the
next T time that it affects it affects
the other connected nodes so here is a
simple network where they're through
communities of twenty five people
connect each each community is connected
by two edges and in interests in like
these seventy five nodes get completely
infected this entire graph isn't
completely infected and simply four
steps but there's more to it than that
oh yeah also because we actually have
the total number of nodes in this in
this network we can actually pull out
more information what is the percentage
of infected notes what is the percentage
of susceptible notes in the system this
is a different way to actually kind of
see what's going on in the network this
is a different way to actually observe
the network but again there's another
there's another portion when you come
talked about epd in epidemiology and the
thing is people eventually recover not
everything is a terminal illness not
everything lasts like stays with you
forever
sometimes you recover and sometimes you
have immunity so you won't get it
infected again so you're no longer
susceptible but you're no longer
affected either and that's consider the
recovery state this is actually called
the SI R model susceptible infected and
recovered so the idea is
like after a certain amount of tea a
certain amount of like infection period
you eventually recover from it and this
is that same model but now with the
actual the each node recovers after time
at time 3 and now the actual the full
graph kind of finds stability at in
seven steps and one more thing um
because each node is an individual if we
actually think that like certain things
have immunity certain not everybody's
equally not everything has the same
chance of getting affected simply by a
contact some people actually have a
stronger immune system some people have
a weaker immune system so that can
actually be given to each node each node
can have a so here I call it alpha each
node has an separate immune system and
you say like in this in this model right
here it's like alpha is the number of
connections a node has to be connected
to before it gets infected so this so
the bun on the bottom left has an awful
one so it gets infected immediately but
then on the bottom right does not get
infected to me because it more of a
resistance however now that that now
that the two adjacent nodes are infected
this this bottom right node does get
infected and so here is same si our
model is simply with different
immunities and rather with the first or
this is the SI model not there's no
recovery in this model but like in the
the first si model the entire system got
infected in four steps here this is
probably a little bit more close to
reality this is a little bit closer to
like how a real system would be here the
entire system gets infected in nine
steps rather than just four staff so it
has eight kind of models reality little
bit more and you could keep on tweaking
it you can keep on tweeting the model
until it actually matches reality and
the importance of that is like once you
actually figure an agent-based model or
a network model that actually resembles
real-life then you could start like
interfering with it you can actually
start like having these let's what like
we can actually start playing with it
like okay we have we realized that this
part of the system is completely
infected what happens if we cut it off
now like do we save do you see of the
population or whatever there's there's
everyone
to play with it and that's the that's
the take away from it that's the fun of
it and again so like here where the
original si model was kind of pretty
straight leaner you see things are a
little bit different here okay
so there's gonna be a coding portion so
get excited all the stuff is in a pipe
again all this stuff is in an eye Python
notebook at my github repository called
Benjamin Ortiz who your PI data 2018 so
let's have fun
here is the thing so this is I graph
it's I graph is actually got a C library
with Python and our wrappers over it and
it's really important that you actually
like so the actual i graph python
library is pretty straightforward to
download you can just pip install it
plotting is a little bit trickier
because you'll need cairo so if you
don't have that installed right off the
bat you're going to need to deal with
that so right this this portion right
here just going to explore how to
actually like play with the graph data
and then I'm gonna show some code later
on like just a quick quick example of
how to applaud it but right now I'm just
kind of care more about the data first
so we're gonna actually go ahead and
just like load the the a graph library
and then we're gonna initialize a graph
so here so you initialize the graph by
simply calling the graph method on eye
graph or the graph function on my graph
and graphs and actually hold a graph
attribute like right here a graph can
have a name we want to name it can also
have information like what kind of graph
is this this is important information
that you actually want to stick on a
graph in general when you share a graph
you want people to have contact you want
people to understand what you're they're
looking at name it and provide some
information so here I actually provide
like a like it's just like this is a
hello world graph and it's a toy graph
for this exact conference and an
important thing to say I'll hover over
right here this is what if you actually
print out the G or the graph object that
you created this is what you get it's
just like it's a it's an object of class
I graph graph
so this is right now just an empty graph
we need to add vertices to it and so we
simply add vertices to it but with a
method called add vertices and you added
the number of actual vertices that you
want so I want four so it's going to add
four a like four unattributed graph
vertex to it so that's gonna be just
simply a vertex of one two three and
four and then you can add attributes by
using this method right here the graph
object dot vs vs is how you actually
access and read and write vertex objects
into a graph so here i want i want i
define three grata vertex attributes
name age and gender and i provide it
with a list of a list of size n and
being the number of vertices you have of
these attributes so it can accept a
string except the boolean it can cept a
number whatever you want to put in there
could store essentially anything so and
then right here you have a graph vertex
sequence this is what a look when you
actually just print out the graph the
the vertex the graph but the cool thing
about these vertices and you'll see this
again with the edges is this is an
iterable you can iterate through this
and actually get the information that's
stored in it and what's stored in a in
the vertex iterable is the actual graph
that it belongs to like what where's
this protects coming from it gives you
the grunt the vertex index within that
graph and it gives you the attribute so
here you see the name the age and the
gender and that's how you're going to
accept the access and play around with
this information gonna iterate through
the vertices to get the information that
you care about and then we're gonna do
the same with edges you can add edges
and the edges accepts a pair a pair of
indices of the vertex indices and we'll
just connect from the first entities to
the second one if it's directed it'll
just have an undirected graph Aveda if
it's undirected just connect the two
things so here like the first three it
connects node 0 so no one knows eo2 no
to knows you know two two three
and we can also give it in attributes in
the same way that we can give a vertex
in attribute it's a graph object es
which is the edge sequence and you just
provide it like you would actually add
like information to a dictionary you
just add it the name of the the variable
and the actual a list of any equals like
the size of the edges or the number of
edges you have of information so here I
just kind of made imagine like a random
attribute called friendship strength
from like like just gave it like random
numbers and this is what it's similar to
the vertex sequence where you have the
graph object you have the index and you
have the attributes and again that's you
want to iterate through that to get that
information and the cool thing like
what's inherit implicit in like edges is
that there is a from and a to like
there's a source node and a to note
whether it's directed or not like when
it writes the actual information down to
create an edge in the graph like there
is going to be a source or there's going
to be a a there's gonna be a target as
well and that's like whether it's
directly or not that neat that's
implicit in the data so you can actually
just iterate through the edges and
actually find which node is the source
known at which node is the edge node and
the the default is that it's the at the
source the source node that it provides
is just the index of the vert the index
of the the the node you're interested in
but you can use that index to read from
read from the vertex list right so here
again like we get the vertex list of all
the target notes from the edge list
so if you print on a graph you'll get
this neat thing so bless you so there's
like the first there's first four
characters so there's you you or D if
it's undirected or directed you'll have
N or a - n means it has its a named
graph as in my vertices are all named
that follow that what follows that is a
tea or a w-4 if it's a weighted graph or
not and then a t4 if it has a type type
actually means that the nodes have
different types which is a bipartite
graph so if you look back at the
recommendation system there was people
and there were objects or like there
were objects and there are attributes
they were stupid different types of
notes and that can be actually put into
the data as a with a special attribute
called type and if you only want the
actual Oh out so um there's two dashes
which is a separator or if there's
there's the number of vertices the
number of edges two dashes and then the
name of the graph and if you only want
the the summary information I graph has
a special helper function are called
summary
I'll provide everything except the edge
Alyssa's oh yeah also these are the
edges in the graph it will provide you a
quick a quick sample of the edges
editing the graph so you can actually do
like sometimes I'll have to play around
with the graph sometimes you have to
iterate in like just like at different
times we'll need to add vertices or
remover disease or add connections and
remove connections and the way you do
that is simply with this method called
delete vertices until each edges and
here we have we just removed everything
from the graphic created a null graph
with zero edges and zero and zero
vertices I just remember them all and
when you want to rebuild things you
cannot and like we originally just
created the graph by providing it with
like a number of vertices like four we
can do the same we can actually create a
graph we can actually add vertices to a
graph by providing it with a list of
names as well so we'll do that here just
in a different way to actually to create
a just a different way to actually
create a graph
also you can use utilize like the edge
sources and target to actually put
attributes in your edges so here I just
kind of used this name of the stores
known in the name of the target note to
create a a edge attribute called
reference or ref to say like where is
the source coming from where is that
target is that's just a different way to
play around with the data to play around
with the the vertex information to
create information in your edges and
then you can delete if you have like
because we deleted the original edge
list but because the graph is the same
it solely identifies that there should
be a friendship strength but it gives it
a value of none if you actually wanted
to leave that you can delete in the same
way that you would delete a dictionary
attribute by using the DL function now
we're gonna go through querying a graph
so the actual fun of exploring graph
data is actually kind of just like
traversing actually exploring like the
edges and the nodes and seeing what is
connected and what's not connected and
that's that that is called traversing a
graph and that's X that's how you
actually explore the graph and the data
that's inside of it so so we're gonna
actually kind of like create a variable
just so like it just to help us actually
explore this Claire was a node the name
was one of the notes so I should
actually find the ID or let's fine let's
let's get just get that so if you
there's a select method that both the
edge sequences and the vertex sequences
have that help you kind of filter down
the these the sequences to the actual
graph that you want if you provide it
with the the parameter that is
equivalent to the actual attribute you
care about like there's a name attribute
and then you give it an equal signs to
what you want to find it will actually
filter that down so we want to actually
filter it down to Claire any vertex that
has the name Claire and it does that now
we have like a a vertex sequence that is
only like with nodes that have Claire as
the name and there's these different
like
boolean operations EQ is equal our key
just use a statement like the equal
operator nei is not equal to less than
these juices are pretty like just short
in terms of like what they they do so
there should be into intuitive so GT is
greater than less than and not in so if
I wanted to find and the way you would
actually use this is you would up upend
this to the the attribute that you're
searching for so if I want to find all
all nodes that have a age of greater
than 20 or all nodes that have that are
in the list of Bob and Alice you just
use the legal have age underscore less
than or name underscore in and this is
what you would have and then the edges
have this the same this the edges have
these same boolean operators but they
also have just a few more as well they
have the source and target so like that
whether the source is in a certain list
of of if the source is in a list of
vertex indices yeah within whether like
if you provide with a sink if you
provide it with if you provide it with a
single list it will give you all
connections between the virtus indices
that are within that list and even
between if you provide it with two list
it will see all edges that connect
vertices from the first list to the
second list independent of direction so
here we're just going to run that real
fast and it then make the the the way
you would actually write it out the same
you would write it out for the firt like
the vertex sequence selections
and there's also this helper function
called incident which provides an edge
list which provides an index of all
edges that are connected to a certain
node those are incident edges to any
know that you're querying for and then
you have another thing called
neighborhood that key provides you with
a list of nodes that a node is connected
to so rather than giving you the edges
it shows you what it's connected to the
actual notice connected to that's the
neighborhood and then again these these
vertex sequences and these edge
sequences are just iterable so you can
actually filter them you can actually
play with them the same way that you
would iterate any kind of list you can
use like the filter operation on it as
well so um so we're gonna actually kind
of like play with some kind of data in
the wild it's a simple I'm going to put
it's called the Star Wars the data that
we're going to pull is a connection
between all Star Wars characters and and
all the movies that they belong that
they've been found in so here it's a
Luke Skywalker has been seen in both The
Revenge of the Sith Return of the Jedi
the Empire Strikes Back it's a simple
connection as a symbol edge list from a
person a character to a movie that
they've appeared in and we're going to
use this actually kind of create a
co-occurrence Network so like what
characters have been seen in the same
movies together so a way so like we've
already been able to build a graph so
let's actually build the graph with data
from a wild so let's kind of create the
notes the name of the notes the name of
the note list should have unique names
so it will just be single like each
individual character and each individual
movie combined in a single one and the
way will actually be able to do that is
by using the set operator to cut make
sure that all the valleys in
are unique and then we're going to
create an edge list which is the we're
just going to zip through the actual
panda's data frame that we loaded in
we're going to zip through all that just
to create the the pair the pair of edge
of vertex vertices that are connected
and then we're going to put that in a
graph and we're going to give it a so
when you're playing with bipartite
graphs and if you've planned on
projecting them it's it generally you
want a type of true and false it just it
needs a type of boolean where the where
the false is one type and the true is
the other type and when you are tending
when you project it it will provide you
with two values the bipartite from one
direction and by pry from the other
direction so if I project if I care
about the movies and what and what
characters they are connected by them I
want a moot I want to see indirect
connection between movies that's one
direction and there's also in directions
there's indirect connection between
people where you get rid of you you
aggregate all the you aggregate all the
movies that are between two people put
that into a single edge and use the
actual number of movies that are shared
between two people as the edge weight
and it's going to provide it like when
we project it's gonna provide us with
two separate two separate graphs we're
going to get we're gonna get Star Wars
films and Star Wars characters from with
a projected graph and here I just have
like I just going to use that
information to push it over and here's
the weight of each of the films which
how much characters that they share
between them
and
I showed earlier that it's important to
be able to aggregate or actually get
information from a from the nodes that
are connected with an edge that can be
done by simply just pulling the sort
like iterating through the edges and
pulling lengths and using and using the
source and target operators and the
reason why that's important is now you
can actually get information like
certain things are informed like how how
important is this connection for
somebody so here and this is not
necessarily this doesn't necessarily
serve as a proxy of importance because
this is like just character appearances
but like within the actual Star Wars
universe some people are just more
prominent than others and so when you
see two people together one person like
it you can infer not necessarily but you
like the idea is that you can fir how
important this relationship is for each
character
if one character shows an all up in all
the Star Wars movies and one person only
shows up in like for Star Wars movies
then the then that relationship is more
important for one one character than it
is for the other because that's that's
more meaningful for the other one
because it's been shown up that that was
a greater percentage of that person's
connections or of that person's
appearances like obi-wan Kenobi only
showed up in six movie or hope that's
not a good example
okay nevermind but anyway that's why you
want actually store information from
notes into the edges that can actually
create just the edges themselves it's
just a way to explore I'm also going to
quickly like this is in the in the
repository that should there was some
some code on how to actually plot with i
graph it needs cairo and car kind of
like pops out into its own little thing
it needs it needs xcode i leaks in mac
so I'm just going to I've run this code
I'll explain it so this would be the
bipartite of this would be the by part
out of the movies this is the bipartite
of the characters or the projected
graphical characters and this is a
filtered projection of the characters so
if you see like the general projection
of the characters you're gonna see this
thing which call the thing on the left
is often considered a hairball it's a
mess you can't necessarily like you
can't necessarily get any kind of
insights from looking at it I guess you
could see up here there's a community of
like people that might matter for
something but but in the bulk of the
graph you don't actually see it's hard
to actually gather insight so what you
want to do is you actually want to
filter it by like like removing edges
that you don't think aren't born so here
is I just removed all edges that were
less than four and then I came up with a
graph on the right if you just remove
all edges and all all edges that are
less than four you'll get a graph if
weight is indicative of importance
you'll you'll only keep the important
edges and the only important notes and
the only important relationships with by
filtering out the ones that are not
important so they all that code is in
the repository
right here Benjamin Ortiz a yacht back
/dc PI data 2018 and then I just want to
conclude with some things I am
organizing a conference on December 8th
if so if you're in DC on Saturday
December 8th and you're interested in
are maybe consider going to this DC
Saturday's conference there's a lot of
cool speakers there there's somebody
who's actually is very prominent in the
data visualization and graph
visualization world Kathy Hawken Innova
and she's a big I'm a big fan of hers so
I'm actually excited she's coming and
also so November the 20th is trans Day
of Remembrance and there and our LGBTQ
or rainbow R is hosting a data thon to
just honor this day and honor the people
who have fallen or who have died a
violent death because they were
transgender we're doing this data thon
so please just follow it using the
hashtag DTD o our data thumb we are
somebody scrapes all the violent deaths
transgendered violent deaths in Cardiff
and they're thinking about making a
slide slide deck kind of honoring these
people there's other projects as well so
if you're interested in want to
collaborate please check it out
and finally here are some resources if
you want to learn more this is the
gremlin graph is a is it gremlin is a
traversal language for graph databases
particularly Apache all the Xingu pop
universe and there's also neo4j which is
his own database which is also a pretty
prominent in the graph database world so
these are two resources actually learn
more about those two graph database
ecosystems and cottony I'm going to
Kathy agnya Nova is a has a bunch of
great visualization tutorials for graphs
so take a look at that and thank you I
hope you learned something
[Applause]
cool oh yeah okay so with with it within
a network the typical network layout
algorithm the the actual proximity
doesn't necessarily matter they the way
these layout these layouts work is that
you want to minimize the number of edge
overlap so you can actually see what's
connected so typically I mean it's not
necessarily the case it's often like
miss attribute if things are like have a
lot of connections they're going to be
closer but that's also not necessarily
always the case because we'd just be
arbitrarily like a edge just went to the
right and there to prevent overlap and
then that will be connected closer to
another vertex so the layout isn't
necessarily the XY of the graph plot is
not necessarily meaningful it's the
number of edges between two nodes that
is meaningful know it that's that's not
necessarily meaningful yeah yeah
so like network X is written in Python
and I graph is written in C so I graph
Python is just a wrapper over the seat I
go with I write because it's just what I
know and I guess people have said that I
graph is a faster because it's written
in C but in the end like if you're
dealing with like a large amount of data
I would definitely recommend using more
than the databases because it's like
it's just in general if you're working
with big data you probably shouldn't be
doing in a memory in the first place
yes so forth directed graph is actually
just that's the layout that's the layout
of the image and that's just like yes
you absolutely can
again like different layouts are meant
to optimize different things and force
directed graphs are the force-directed
layout is just optimizing a different
thing
hang on yeah
can you expound Allegiant before but I'd
be happy to talk it over and see if we
could like brainstorm it together after
this yeah oh okay so you mean like like
RN ends and like stuff like so ever
cnn's yeah like I mean when they're
explained
they're explained with graphs and I
don't know enough about it so I can't
really explain it but basically like
each if you if you look at a this is
like my guess is if you look at a CNN
chart like where you have like the
different like layers
I guess each each connection between one
layer to the next is a different
intuition going going into that again I
don't necessarily know this field that
well so but yeah that's that's what my
guess is just traversing through it
Cheers
cool
[Applause]